our vision is to to make
all kinds of games all kinds of things
that you can connect
you can control through your phone that
happen in
reality and you know we see it also
happening in other industries
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today
it's a journey each one is different
unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley
in partnership with leumitech sponsored
by hippo insurance
opposed labs touring hillel at stanford
leap and in media partnership with ctec
when technology and the physical world
intertwine amazing things happen
meet ron breitman founder and ceo of
gigantic the creators of the chloe app
ron mba has been managing online
marketing teams for about 19 years
at various companies such as 888 party
gaming and etoro
for seven years ron was the ceo of
performance revenues an international
mobile marketing firm
meet ron ron breitman welcome to
20-minute leaders all the way from
the gigantic offices indeed
now i know why you call the company
gigantic because they say oh yeah i'm in
the gigantic offices
they're not that gigantic but
it rolls off the tongue from a
bachelor's
and master's in psychology to an mba
to working in incredible companies as vp
marketing
and a you know in etoro but you're also
previously at silicon and you you've
done quite a bit
now ceo of a gigantic and now you're
creating games
and you're shaping the way a lot of
people are going to experience the world
and gaming is one of those
domains and industries that i have on
the top of my list to do a deep dive
because
it is the real it's that's where we're
headed and i don't know nearly enough
about it and so i'm gonna be
asking you a lot of questions in these
next 20 minutes but the first and
most important one is how do you get
into gaming
in the first place from from psychology
and from sales and marketing
yes yes i've done a very long way with
some detours
in it but eventually i ended up in the
gaming industry but that was already
like almost
20 years ago or 19 to be precise
so i just found myself in that industry
and and i very soon realized that this
is the industry to be in
it it's not only the gaming industry it
was the internet industry at the
beginning
and then it evolved into a specific
channel of
gaming but it's the internet
basically or now it's mobile
so so yes you're definitely right about
uh your passion to explore the gaming
industry much further
uh because uh this is the industry now
where everything is happening the
fastest
the the most exciting the most
innovations the most money
the the most growth and we can see it in
there
in the public companies that their
prices are soaring
and and and we can also see it at home
you know everyone is playing all the
time
and all ages and all uh all walks of
life
uh we just we we all became gamers
all of us and you don't have to play on
a playstation or something like that
everyone has a
very very good gaming device in their
hands
and they can play five minutes or five
hours every day
and it's happening all over us
so uh so that's definitely the industry
now i think that what we're doing
specifically in gigantic
is actually quite amazing and i know him
strangely saying it about ourselves but
but it is true because
we're doing real innovation in the
gaming space
and it's not an easy thing to do because
uh
you know if if we look around us
either here in israel or worldwide we
see that most of
the gaming companies are imitating and
replicating and duplicating with very
slight modifications
and many other things that are already
there
so there's not that much real
re-innovation
and we're actually carving
a new vertical within the gaming space
so i have to say what we're doing yes
reading
we're doing something that's called the
connected reality this
this is how we call it uh connected
reality
is we're bringing the player
the ability to control real gaming
machines real
physical objects in the real world to
control it through their mobile phones
and to watch whatever they're doing
through live video streaming
so you you can be in one side of the
of the globe and to control gaming
devices on the other side of the globe
in real time with live video streaming
and our first app is called chloe
and in chloe most of the machines are
clone machines
although not only i will tell you in a
second about the other machines that we
have now when you say machines what do
you actually mean by
by machines i mean that we actually have
currently we have 260 real
claw machines at our offices we have
another office and not in tel aviv right
now our office
and that i'm talking from is
in tel aviv but we have uh an office in
the neighboring city which is uh
patatiqua
and over there we have uh one thousand
square meters and we're just doubling it
to two thousand and we have lots and
lots of machines with lines of machines
and it's like two double decker machines
and they're connected to
internet lines and they have each
machine has one camera in the front and
one camera in the side
and they if actually visiting that place
is is a very interesting experience
i have i had many visitors
so you're welcome next uh next time we
meet
let's make it at the machine studio i
can
sure it's a very interesting experience
i had many uh
people come to visit it and people from
abroad
very high ranking uh people from uh
from google facebook uh other
competitors even and they all were
amazed by
uh by how how this looks it's it
it has some unique vibe to that place
because everything is moving all the
time
and there is no one standing in front of
the machines
so it's really cool experience and you
also see the machines and
and they're they look very nice and we
have different kinds of machines so it's
it's something that you have not seen
that i can promise you
how does the connected part work because
obviously that's that's the killer
feature here
so the you have you download chloe
okay on your phone android or ios
apple and immediately we connect you
with
live stream to one of the machines and
you're controlling that machine you're
actually moving the claw
uh you're controlling the claw and you
see what you're doing through the live
video
and when you manage to catch a prize you
get it delivered through mail to your
doorstep
wow so it's like double the
the excitement than any other regular
game where you
only control virtual things that are
happening on your screen and nothing is
actually happening in reality so here
something is actually happening in
reality and
it it creates a completely different
like you're gameplay doing something
that is actually happening and
it is actually happening so uh the
the the gameplay the experience is much
more immersive
right it's much more exciting
uh and and you really feel the
excitement
of trying to catch that item
so when you do manage to get it the the
excitement is
is is very great and also when you don't
you get
extremely mad uh
and and we can see that with our players
you know they they love us
and and but when they're angry they're
still also extremely angry at us
and uh although we we let them
you know we we we don't play around with
it we let them
exercise their skills and and it is a
game of skill
at least the way that we are doing it
and not necessarily in in the
arcade center next to your house uh
sometimes
it the the operator of these machines
this is a
trade secret i can share um
in the arcade center if you go most of
these machines
are set up in a way that they have a
payout ratio so it's not really
based on your skill more on if someone
just won the machine or not
which means that if someone just won the
machine don't play
don't play yeah don't play it so with us
it's not like that you can win
few times in a row and it really depends
on your skill
and and actually players
win all the time almost a lot of the
times we ship
monthly about 130 000
pieces every month so we ship a lot of
stuff
and that needs a whole startup by itself
just managing the shipment of 130 000
but but ron take me up take me up 30 000
feet in the air right now you were
talking about claws and you know
eisen as an outsider and i imagine a lot
of people listening you know i'm
imagining this big factory a lot of
claws and i'm thinking to myself wow
like okay this is a new type of thing
on one hand you know yes it's clause but
you're actually talking to me by the
whole
a new connected world a new universe
where people are interacting with their
phones where before it was
it ended with the phone but now there's
this whole new dimension and a whole new
layer
that what they're doing actually impacts
the physical world
what what does this mean what does this
mean for us for society
it means something very big because uh
our vision is to to make
all kinds of games all kinds of things
that you can connect
you can control through your phone that
happen in
reality and you know we see it also
happening in other industries like
uh you know you have uh waze that
navigates you through the
through the road or you have a taxi that
lets you
invite a taxi or there's so many things
now that are connected your phone is is
not only
living in the virtual space it's also
influencing other stuff that's happening
outside and
it didn't happen this way in games
except for
maybe virtual reality games where you do
have some kind of
interaction with the reality but it's
not really reality
so what we're doing is really
interaction with
reality and and this
opens up as you said a completely new
space a completely new
room to to play with and this is what
this is our vision
this is what we're already doing so as
you said claw machines are one thing but
in our vision and we already started to
do it it's
it doesn't end with clone machine it can
it never ends we can do it in
so so many other games and we already
started
so right now within chloe you can play
a miniature uh version of soccer
mini golf even basketball we have
we we develop our own machines and we
invent them and we develop them and so
we
we developed a machine that you have a
cannon
with the ball and you're shooting it
into the basket
and with mini golf you have a small
golfing
uh um you know pole and you
you do the the mini golf as you do
outside
and the next thing that we already
started to develop is bowling
it's not live yet but we but we bought
real bowling alleys two big
bowling alleys the long ones you know
the real ones
and now we have to to build it and to
set it up
and i think bowling is going to be a
huge hit
so so this is this is what we're doing
and what's the grand vision
of of a company like this so on one hand
you have these
games that are very interactive they're
very engaging
there it sounds like people experience
on a different emotional level than a
lot of other games but
what what are you like what does this
actually mean like what
what is the vision for this it means
that
uh we're gonna be a gigantic company
and then there's gonna be many other
companies that probably that's going to
imitate
us and it's going to be a whole new
vertical
within gaming it it already is and
there's already a companies that
are competitors of ours but it's going
to be it's going to go into the
mainstream uh
very fast it's already happening just
last week
we we climbed into the top
20 most downloaded games on the us
wow store uh yes and we also the top
100 crossing apps there
and and the game has been live for about
three years now
and and it's this year it experienced
the massive growth
it started with the coronavirus last
year but
this year has been a huge growth and it
we we expect it to continue growing
significantly
and we see that more and more companies
pay attention to that
also lots of media coverage because it's
it's something that people can connect
you know somehow you know anyone
i tell about this says what they you
know there's
some disbelief at the beginning and it's
also what happens to our players
uh but very fast when you digest the
idea
when you actually play you realize that
yeah
it is true you know we're actually
playing on a real live
machine and and and and immediately
you say well how did i think of it it's
so logical you know it's so
it's so intuitive and it it even
you know it that even has some kind of
nostalgic element to it because
anyone has played real either claw
machines or arcade machines
at some point or at many points right so
so
it has some personal connection to
to everyone somehow so no no
i think that's so cool now ron take me
back a little bit
you're doing your bachelor's and
master's in psychology
it doesn't seem like you did too much
psychology later on you know
in the in the traditional sense of
psychology but where do you find
your academia play into your day-to-day
if at all do do you feel that your and
your understanding of psychology is
impacting in any way should perform the
journey that you're on
so for the majority of my years i
thought that
my two degrees in psychology were a
waste of time
but only recently i realized that it was
not
probably a complete waste of time well
first thing i met my wife there so
that's that's one but i think also
it does definitely help me in my
professional life
uh and maybe in two ways so
obviously one is what you would expect
you know in the gaming industry
it's a lot about psychology the
psychology of the player
how to keep it the player entertained
and engaged
and how to make them obviously pay and
come back
you know come back is is probably the
the biggest challenge for all games
how to make the player come back to the
game and yeah there's lots of stuff that
go
into that but that's really about uh
very specific about maybe a game design
and stuff like that so
probably not the right place now to to
go into that because it's very long
and the other thing that might be even
more
um meaningful or influential
is actually the ability to uh
to be a founder and and ceo of a company
which is a challenge a big challenge by
itself
because you have employees and you have
clients or players or users and you have
investors and you have so many other
things going on
and and you just need to learn how to
navigate
within that right and that's always the
complex and challenging uh
thing and i think you know to know
a little bit about psychology both how
other people
think and react and and what motivate
them
is one but also about yourself uh
so i think it did help me in that manner
a little bit
no i can only imagine how how big a part
it must play
especially as you're dealing with a
company that at the end is creating
interactions and whenever you're
creating an interaction
if you have an insight into the science
behind this interaction and you're able
to understand
trends and you're able to understand why
people do what they do and explain that
with you know a little bit of research
and some background that that's much
stronger than you know than intuition
and i think that that's really amazing
but one i have a few more questions
they're not about gaming they're more
about you if you're ready for them
sure go ahead all right so we'll go back
to middle school and high school
what was your favorite subject
wow
i think in many times for many people
though it really depends on the teacher
yeah so good teachers is
is a hard thing to come by but it's very
important
and i also see it with my kids now uh i
think
maybe uh literature
yeah maybe something like that but might
have
something to do with the fact that my
mother was a literature
teacher now i understand er
and who you know throughout your career
personal or professional would you
consider
a role model of some kind or an
inspiration
wow uh i think i i had a few
i had a few and maybe one of the
the the the influential ones
was joni asia
founder and ceo of idol which is an
extremely successful company
and and it was it was very interesting
to
to see him manage that company because
it was a startup
and i joined from day zero there was no
nothing then and and
and to see him grow the company and
recruit people
and talk with their reporters and talk
with investors
and look at the numbers and getting
involved with all the different
areas with the technology technology
with marketing
with everything else uh also all the
the mistakes that he did all the all the
wrong things that he did yeah it all
helped me back then when i looked at him
i said well i'm
never gonna be a ceo i never i don't
want and i will
never ever choose this kind of path and
somehow
i did so it did help me to see him
do do this kind of thing that helped me
uh realize uh one one of the ways to do
that
obviously is not the only one but it was
a very interesting wrong
role model and what are three words
that you would use to describe yourself
wow you have some difficult questions
wow three words to describe myself
i think i am um
i i would like i would like to think
that i'm a relatively good person
i don't know if i can say that i am and
another thing i i believe in
personal improvement
what other thing i think
i i have
well i love that
more difficult than running a company
yeah i i you know i
wanna i love the you know i i love it
where people take a lot of time and when
they really think i think that it's
to me that's that's part of the learning
and and trying to you know it's
impossible to to come to draw down to
three words but but i gained so much
inspiration and i had so much fun
over these past 20 minutes and i love
the perspective of looking at this new
market i love the perspective of the
psychology but the more of the
perspective of
you know how how it creating
interactions that are really meaningful
for people
and it it's you you it's a theme that
came up over and over again here this
idea of
creating something that is that is
different that is creating a positive
you know experience on the people using
it across the board whether it's
visiting the factory in perth or the or
the
place or it's the person who's operating
the claw from from afar
or it's developing the game so it's all
around it sounds amazing and thank you
very much for your time this was
wonderful
you are very welcome thank you very much
for having me
and thank you yeah thank you very much